[Música]
tenemos
muy buenas tardes
seguramente ustedes
en este momento se están preguntando
quién es esta persona
simple y sencillamente es mi padre
jorge lima money
y por quien me acompaña porque me aporta
en este escenario
porque sus enseñanzas
sonido
durante tres años
trate de generar siempre el triangular
será el fin de transformarlo
y lindo año de primaria será la
convocatoria para elegir al comité
ejecutivo de la sociedad ventas
de inmediato y si mi planilla
de inmediato metí a registrar
y de la elección y el resultado
acudo a ver a mi maestro
era director de la escuela
y de manera confirme
le pido que le ayude a cambiar la
rotación
y qué
la respuesta fue contundente
y es algo que ha marcado
con 6
aprende a respetar la voluntad de los
demás
el maestro el director era precisamente
mi padre
porque el himno mundo
pero el asunto no se quedó ahí
y me dice acude a felicitar a los niños
que tengan a felicitarla y abraza con
esto
a ver si a los niños aparecen las niñas
y cuando voy a saludar la muestra la
mano
está mal es claro
las maestras remedios orales
ya para entendernos
en cada
me dice
en esta vida
se ganan y se pierden
pero debes
debes de aprender a respetar las normas
a respetar las leyes y lo más importante
siempre
al negarse a la voluntad de la sociedad
esto es lo que a mí me ha trazado
cada una de actividades
de lo que me ha marcado porque
seguramente ustedes
todos ustedes saben que desde hace
muchos años
no se respetan las normas
en algunos lados se violentan las leyes
y tenemos
otro problema muy fuerte
la producción
todos la hemos padecido
y precisamente cuando a mí me invitan a
este escenario
lo primero que me preguntes
qué voy a decir en estos 15 minutos
no quedes con ellos
hoy está
pero si comprendí que lo que tenían que
hacer
ese es interesarles mi coraje
mi insatisfacción por no tener el país
por tanto
que tenemos que hacer con laborar esta
es para mí
son las armas fundamentales para crear
una realidad general y lograr la
transparencia que tanto queremos
pero tenemos que hacerlo de frente y
tenemos que escuchar porque como bien
como tiempo dijo lohan vais
tienes que luchar
contra la revolución y la podredumbre
si no vas a hacer si no vas a ser parte
de él
hoy estoy ante él pensando gente
inteligente gente capaz gente honesta
que estoy seguro que nos podemos ayudar
entre todos para cambiar el rumbo de
este país
esto esto de veras que es muy importante
cuando uno va analizando
el por qué no podemos hacer las cosas de
manera
porque tenemos que seguir una línea si
no cubre el espacio a la necesidad por
lo que quieren algunos otros
amigas y amigos es muy importante pelear
nuestra producción es muy importante
luchar contra ello
en ellos
nosotros presidimos una asociación civil
que cuando empezamos a generarla
por parte de la sociedad existía
incertidumbre porque antecedentes hay
bastantes
decían que creyeron
y que los recursos nos íbamos a aplicar
de manera
hoy les puedo decir a cada uno de
ustedes que esta asociación civil tiene
representación en más de la mitad
de los municipios de esta unidad
relativa
directamente integrado por hombres y
mujeres que tienen el único deseo de
ayudar y de verter pesar a su principio
y vemos local
hemos apoyado con de especias
hemos dado al material de la
construcción
y hemos apoyado a instituciones de
educación está mal esto mobiliario
equipos de sonido hemos transformado y
ayudado a la mejora de centros de salud
y aunque no lo es
todo esto
los dos hechos de manera gratuita
porque hoy hay de verdad lo español
no es que tengamos escuelas
en estas condiciones
y algo de todo el país hoy no es
correcto
que niñas y niños no tengan en la estima
suficiente ni la estructura como para
poder desarrollarse y ser los profes los
profesionistas que tanto queremos
por eso es que ir
yo terminaría siendo más
como me lo dijo mi padre hace 50 años
a veces gana
y a veces decir
hemos perdido por tanta condena
qué bueno
yo los invito
yo los invito a que sean los diferentes
aquí en el torneo
así es
a que le ayuden a transformar y hagamos
una revolución social una revolución de
conciencias y que empecemos a esta
revolución lograr los grandes para todos
de entrada la transformación
[Aplausos]
[Música]